[Música]
jorge a rua
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e aí galera que aceite meu canal tudo
com vocês
estou gripado em porque estas são paulo
o meia hora olha mas também atenção no
meu nariz e de cravos e que acabou de
abrir esse vídeo foi à clínica logo não
gostei explicar mais uma vez que o
espírito toda vez que você esquece e
clicar em gosto e youtube começa a parar
de te mandar os meus vídeos no instagram
a mesma coisa a viu a foto não curtiu
que está ganhando é mais na hora que
postou não é mais assim o que importa
dois minutos a aparecer que importa não
vai ficar jogando foto e fica jogando
foi aleatória na tela então citou kurt
as minhas fotos ele entende que você
gosta das minhas fotos e vai sempre
ficar se mudando mesmo com o youtube
você clica em gostei ele continua
enviando então não esquece não deixa o
final do vídeo que você sempre esquece a
conta os vídeos carregados lá em cima o
click gostei aqui tá o evento que já
aqui prestar atenção nisso e clique
gostei
valeu você que os próximos shows
enquanto isso vou dançar sem música para
você ver como é ridículo mais uma venda
na internet
todo mundo fala que o dia todo mundo
falar isso agora reboladinha isso aquela
que todo mundo fala isso com certeza do
dia em todas as datas e locais a itabom
bauru presidente prudente piracicaba
belém no pará
bragança capanema natal meu deus natal
para consolidar esse fortaleza todos os
ingressos você comprar é no meu site
aqui é nós tamo junto e está lá no site
quem quiser comprar ingresso lá tem sido
estava no avião mexendo no celular
eu me achei aqui no celular ea senhoria
do meu lado olhando após colocar a mexer
com uma ressalva serginho sempre vou
assistir o longa seria do meu lado me
olhando porque eu tava vendo o pessoal
nesse hora que não tem nada para o sul
da cidade está assistindo
curiosa a a apae eu tenho raiva de gente
curiosa então tanta raiva me entrava
ninguém nunca fui um amigo por toda vida
desgraça os fica olhar minhas coisas um
monte de gente curiosa isso acontece
muito em cidade pequena cidade pequena
meu amigo pode não ser nada um jumento
morto no meio da pista o que é que foi
feito e foi catar qna televisão porque
sem essa novela acabe é na cidade de
interior se você parar olhando pro céu
entanto nada vai parar umas 30 pessoas
que sonham que foi campeão e meia
e ele me disse você olha é fácil eu não
tava nem dava para ver nada ele vai
falar é também também não é errado aí
não me chamo um táxi acaba vendo aí as
coisas apae eu nunca pensei que eu ia
ver isso aí inventando eu tenho raiva de
gente curiosa mãe é curiosa no hardman
que a minha mãe não é curiosa de um
jeito muito estranho que eu às vezes até
no facebook que mexer no computador eu
vejo um vídeo interessante para o
programa chamou e falou mãe vive aqui o
vídeo de si disse passarinho ela vem
mamãe eu tô velha na meta a tela tem
comentado pela moeda até o menino lobo
coisa como é que é a lua a carlos
almeida luís ela começa a chegar um
pouco mais só que tem que tomar
distância sem padrinho é o que é isso aí
nós não só achei bonitinho mesmo o
passarem brincando com a criança aqui ó
a nike não a passar igor come brinca
é a cabo vídeos foram caboca um jardim
bem rapidinho só me brincando com os
alimentos que o que aconteceu com o
passarinho é de 1 cm é porque não só tem
seu charme é só porque mais achei bonito
ou então que morreu passarem depois
menino matou eu digo seu amor à mãe só
achei bonito cheio uma cena pra ver que
eu achei bonito ou em cena com o rio
passarinho morrer mesmo assim acabei a
minha mãe acabou o vídeo morreu aí meu
filho caso a meta é caso hoya casa onde
morreu o poeta beleza termina o vídeo
continua em linha com que o facebook
trabalho pesquisar uma moeda em mim sair
a quem a neusa que mora aqui perto de
casa
é o que sei lá mas sei que é neusa não
olha a foto na morreu senna morreu
facebook facebook a desgraça porque
facebook desgaste que só tem disgrafia
ele através da web da imagem do bandido
os policiais batons ladrões ou mandante
abriu o card completo a incomodar de
abril crê e olha datena situação tensa
que não ajudar o pt ficou potoca
televisão de espanha cedo o gosto de
salsicha na mão cara primeiro pouco de
manhã por 141 a tarde na marginal tietê
ficou puto assim vai mexer no facebook a
diferença do facebook atrás
no facebook um aviso imagens fortes você
deseja ver esta imagem isso é duas vezes
pior que quando aparece esse aviso aí
que você fica com vontade de ver o que
tem por trás daquela vida você tá
mexendo facebook de saber que a imagem
sportv isso se falar há a imagem forró e
respeito à parte mas foco que [ __ ]
imagens não carai sp capô rebocadores
acostumado é você clica 11 e tira tira ç
ã rã herói num click porque eu sou
curioso eu sou grosso é o campeão ódio
quanto o facebook quando assistir um
vídeo o vídeo acaba eu não sei o que
aconteceu
gente caindo bem vindo facebook a galera
cair no chão haikai a pessoa está
filmando se desespera pára de filmar no
céu foi aconteceu com pessoas aqui
morreu quando eu assisti o vídeo que
tranquilo quarto andar de skate quem é
esse homem é e ela gera dúvidas se você
não vai acreditar no que aconteceu ao
assistir o vídeo aqui de boa mas que não
acontece aqui olha eu fico canalho ué
sam que morreu e cadê o resto vi para
saber se aconteceu eu fico ou num mundo
por acabar agora não deu no youtube cara
cair de skate vídeo completo eu não acho
que esse cara meu deus o que aconteceu
esse cara - será que eu posso rir ou não
o que vocês que eu sou curioso não tem
coisa para despertar minha curiosidade
no mundo deixando sei se vocês são assim
não vai eu tenho eu tenho problema e
isso é um problema já richa não sei se
acontece com vocês eu não sei mas eu
tenho um problema quando eu vejo
mensagem de luto no facebook e no
facebook luto
vai em paz amigo que me surge aquela
dúvida como foi que essa pessoa morreu e
ninguém possa assim luto meu amigo entre
paredes aos interessados morreu andar de
bicicleta não sei como alguém no
facebook absorver um filósofo é a fota
pessoa preto e branco assim o texto os
caminhos se abrem onde as pessoas se vão
quem vai não fica e eu fico cara e
doutores morreu é sempre algo mais
curioso e mais frágil que o quê pergunta
nos comentários meu deus como foi que
morreu é a pessoa responde morreu
deixando a grande lacuna no meu peito a
pessoa perguntou responde a outra pessoa
a vida é um sopro ou multiuso
ele morreu no entanto fica sem saber o
edu fez a pessoa que postou tem mais
fotos de gente bacana pessoas que marcam
18 pessoas
aí outra pessoa possa lutar pessoas se
vão pessoas se vêem eu te amo você
também a vida é um momento de
fragilidade onde o mundo se encontra com
a existência o look aparece embaixo a
pessoa marcou mais 18 que seu avô 18h é
o edno fez outra pessoa tasso beije
abrace viva amanhã pode não ser o amanhã
e sim o futuro falou carla olha o meu
deus alguém me fala de que essa pessoa
morreu meu deus eu vou ali e não sei se
a pessoa tem uma foto em preto e branco
da pessoa simpática e branco em cima do
cavalo foto preto e branco na cadeira um
monte de fotos em preto e branco 8
facebook o pessoal está aqui vai saber
certeza que sabe aquela foto em preto e
branco ea legenda os cães são como as
lanchas
as motos são como os jet skis e os
pedestres são como os banhistas vá em
paz amigo falou meu deus meu deus eu não
vou conseguir sair de casa se não souber
o que aconteceu essa pessoa meu é do
facebook a última pessoa a falar te amo
vai país tapar a boca as tags 122 anos
não pensará por isso que a foto postada
tudo em preto e branco neto que era luto
é porque as fotos cada tipo dela novo só
tinha quebrado o que acontece quando o
encontro quando eu realmente seu foi
aconteceu já estava numa busca tão
grande quando eu encontro e descobre que
a pessoa morreu
além do tanta importância quanto deveria
dar cara meu irmão sou merda mesmo eu
disse que eu odeio gente curiosa e eu
sou mais curioso que todas essas pessoas
curiosas sobre realmente o próprio e
padre tom eu nem sou um hipócrita eu sou
um bando de palco teus um bom vou me
tratar isso se você gostou desse vídeo
você já sabe o que fazer é só clicar
embusteira aqui no youtube que você
também uma pessoa curiosa que você
comente aqui em baixo alguma situação
curiosa que aconteceu com você comete
aqui embaixo no facebook secos quem está
no twitter um site no twitter que na
roupa nas madrugadas da rp tá nesse
vídeo aqui minhas redes sociais essas
que estão aparecendo aqui caso você quer
me seguir me acompanhar mas ainda
estamos juntos aí valeu é nóis 'back to